Ukrainian military
leaders are promising
more attacks on Russian targets.
As they say,
they're getting better
at identifying the enemy's locat
The latest is a strike
on the town of Chula KVCR
in the southern region,
which Ukraine says killed or wou
Russian troops.
Meanwhile, the Russian defense
ministry says Ukraine
was able to target a military ba
in the Donetsk region
because soldiers
there were using their cell phon
Moscow says 89
people were killed in that attac
but Ukraine puts the death
toll in the hundreds.
Ukraine also claims
it destroyed an ammunition warehouse
in a strategic hub in the eastern
Luhansk region.
A local official says
they watched Russian forces
moving in weapons
and vehicles for two weeks
before they struck.
Let's go live now to London and
Clare Sebastian.
Good morning to you, Clare.
So what more are you learning ab
Ukraine's attacks
on Russian forces in both
Kefka and McCabe?
So these
are two
attacks, Rosemary,
which appeared
to have happened a day apart.
Which revealed
potentially a similar strategy
of hitting locations
where a lot of troops
and a lot of equipment were conc
But they're different in the sen
that when it comes to the attack
Russia is admitting a death toll
It's increased.
The death toll is now at 89.
Ukraine, meanwhile, had claimed
that 400
Russian soldiers were killed
and around 300 wounded.
They now say they're clarifying
We don't know exactly what
the numbers are as of yet.
It seems that perhaps
the rubble
is still
being picked over in that region
but a very unusual one for Russi
to admit
that any of its soldiers were ki
And second, for Ukraine
to claim
responsibility for a major strik
It does not tend to do that
when it comes to to keep clear,
that's in the southern region,
just in the Russian occupied
territory, just across the river
from Kurdistan,
where it retreated from in in No
Russia is not saying anything ab
The only information we have now
comes from the Ukrainian side
where they say around 500
Russian soldiers were killed or
So two episodes
that reveal
perhaps the Ukrainian strategy
to try to break the deadlock
on these front lines.
But the information flow around
is quite different at this point